other than this movie being about you
know the personal triumphs of overcoming
the fact that you're dying there is one
simple lesson in this movie and that is
never meet your heroes so what I've been
saying The Fault in Our Stars so The
Fault in Our Stars is based off of a
book I was going into this movie I knew
nothing about it I didn't know anything
about who wrote it all I knew is those
like alright another teen romance movie
for tweens and let's get this over with
[ __ ] I was wrong this movie's actually
it's not like that this movie's actually
based off of a book written by John
Green I don't know if you know who John
Green is or that YouTube channel
vlogbrothers which is what he's from or
his brother from scishow you guys watch
scishow if you don't you were not
married to science point is is due to
youtuber and I like seeing youtubers
have success so for some odd reason and
it just like seeing that the movie is
really smart first of all it's not sappy
it's not some sappy shitty love stories
like I Receptus and to be together it's
not like that ultimately it's it's the
personal triumph of overcoming the fact
that these people have cancer shailene
woodley has cancer it's like one of
those she's doomed she's going to die
shailene Woodley's really good in the
movie and she plays an interesting
character I like her character I like
her playing the character then she meets
this dude who's really he's optimistic
he's like the best human being ever he's
like such a nice human you're like if
everyone was like you there would be no
problems at all on earth and the two of
them are an optimistic pair who are like
no we don't dwell on the fact that we
have cancers not like oh woe is us we
have cancer they poke fun at the fact
that they have cancer they live their
lives and they don't let cancer get them
down they find a kindred spirit among
the two of them and so they start they
embark on their quests and their love
journey which actually does sound sappy
but it's not done in a sappy way this
movies like Garden State with cancer
those are the kind of praises you don't
see on the blu-ray box and for the life
of me I don't know why this should be on
there it's what it's like I like people
like Gus the strong supporting character
is important in a romance you gotta like
both people to get like the girl you
gotta like the dude I like Gus I guess
is his name in this movie I like him I
like people like him in the world he
says what he wants he does what he wants
he knows what he wants he's not a dick
about it is a likable guy I like seeing
the parents interact because like
shailene woodley says in the movie the
only thing worse than dying of cancer is
having your kid die of cancer
so it's interesting seeing her parents
deal with it it's it's all just it's a
hard shitty road this movies not only
relatable to people who might have
cancer might know someone who has cancer
but it's relatable to people who are
alive if you have a pulse you pretty
much relate to this movie this movies
funny it's tear-jerking it's smart smart
dialogue in a movie like this is really
really important you don't have smart
dialogue if you don't have good
characters it's just sappy [ __ ]
needless to say this movie surprised the
hell out of me I went there an adult man
to watch this movie I was like this is
made for tweens Oh God and I walked out
truly know I would be missing out if I
didn't watch the movie this movie
illustrates the premise that there is a
difference between a death sentence from
cancer and being defeated by cancer this
movie uses a concept and an illness of
death to show you true optimism and it
does it with good characters good
dialogue an interesting situational
circumstance fact it is The Fault in Our
Stars is worth buying on blu-ray all
right so what's the biggest tear-jerking
movie for you what's the one whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more for science